yeah they look at the camera you look
drunk I'm Victoria Beck and this is
Albert Einstein and we are at the DOJ
pet boutique here in Beverly Hills
the Theo G pet boutique is a full
concierge service for you doc I help
style your dog's Liberty dogs we have
the best fake loft for dogs my name is
Erin and my dog's name is Yeti spaghetti
Yeti was actually found in the street
yetis everyday style is just a small
bandana like this one she'll wear
Halloween outfits like weird eyeball
goggles I'm kind of nervous about how
yet he's going to get styled we're kind
of simple outdoor kind of people my name
is Alex and mrs. Jackson Jackson is a
pain in the butt that's his personality
he's hyper he's acting Jackson I tried
to dress him festive if we're ever going
to a function or a party I try to match
him to the occasion when hoping that the
stylist really captures his personality
I would like to see Jackson and
something that really exotic I
California cool that's always been my
dream to be him on a surfboard my name
is Monica and this is my dog Lucille
Ball I met Lucy five years ago she who
was actually a rescue I don't go like
crazy with the outfits I want Lucy's
outfit to like be like my matching
accessory I want like a full ensemble
decked out looking go out
for Yeti I picked out a more tomboyish
look I picked out this camo luxe dress
it's still girly without being
over-the-top for Jackson
he's very Kelly living be cheap I picked
this little cute tank top with these
swim trunks where the butt is still
hanging out so for Lucy I wanted to
bring out her inner fiance I picked this
super cute dress and on top then put
this little leopard fur jacket to finish
it off some pearl necklaces on the beach
[Music]
there's a little bit of nip slip so she
might be uncomfortable enough on a
hiking trail I think she would rather
run free and just show off this necklace
bling I think she's a star she like
really found her look in this process I
was wanting Beyonce and I got like
Audrey Hepburn meets Beyonce it's
exactly what I wanted him to look like
nautical beachy California he's so ready
to hit away take the thing off me and
let me run free looks very sophisticated
a very sexy I feel totally cool like I'm
ready to hit a wave